what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are back for secret Invasion episode
five today John how's it going I am great how are
you doing well coy so excited to see who dies and
comes back ladies and gentlemen you know what to
do please go ahead leave a like on this video my
gosh there's a good case for why this show is
great oh I am setting us up for a transition to
something we agreed to before the strike commenced
so it is okay according to the rules hey Webheads
we got a spectacular sponsor today in case the
fire here to tell you anybody can be a hero you
don't even need a radioactive spider introducing
the Spider-Man X case defy collection turning your
phone into a piece of the Marvel Universe the
Spider-Man mask case is no less than your very
own super suit reminding us all we've got
the power to swing into action and make a
difference but if you're feeling a tad symbiotic
the Venom pattern case is right up your alley
it's some of that classic better matchiness give
your phone a touch of anti-hero chic or if you're
feeling the need for some flip Splat sap action
the Spider-Man pattern case is as close as it
gets to having spidey's classic banter in
your pocket and of course you can't forget
the classic Spider-Man hanging case echoing
the Timeless wisdom with great power comes
great responsibility I mean my favorite pick
it's got to be the Spider-Man mask case but
how about you ready to thrip into action with
your very own hashtag Spider-Man X casify case
don't hang around like a radioactive spider
swing over to the link in the description box
for the Spider-Man X case defy collection
make sure you tag your webtacular selfies
with you everything you're seeing on screen
right now until next time stay spectacular
oh yeah and I should probably mention we're gonna
be at Comic-Con this Saturday one o'clock P.M the
Neo Auditorium I think is what it's called if
you're going to Comic-Con please stop by would
love to see you there can you hear me so you
need to make a space this was not the Russians
it was not sir the hospital is full of Scrolls
so do you have clearance then stay outside
but even when he's out he's in
that yeah it's a great shot
this guy I like him remember his
name everyone ah yeah but you know
you should be proud G it calls him G
should be proud homie yeah dude you ordered
Fury's death when you knew Vara would never
do it you had another chance to kill Fury
today and you didn't take it you're weak
G makes me start to wonder why should we
whoa yeah definitely did not see that coming
whoa
graphic and the only reason Fury was on
that Motorway was because his traitor wife
to fight my director she traded you and you send
some of our people to vara's house and kill her
everyone go kill her
I'd like to order a pizza place extra
pepperoni make sure he knows it wasn't
just the Russians who did this it was
the Russians with the help of Scrolls
what prove to him there are Scrolls living here
in Russia and that they must all be eliminated
war and if we don't get what we want well then
we all do what we've prepared for sacrifice
G your plan gets more confusing by
the second where's the president
damn people's just giving out classified
information lock this whole place down right now
he's in a suit he's in a
suit calm down do something
your service to the president
tonight but I'm here now you can go
and be out of your scroll ass man in about 60
seconds the footage of you killing Maria Hill
is gonna get off every news program all across
the hemisphere 60 seconds you're gonna become
the most wanted and hated man on the planet the
people love Maria so Tick Tock Nick it's ouch
could have just also shot him
consider this a preview Nick
because if you ever get within
100 yards of the president again
I'm gonna make sure you get the whole show go grab
it I'm coming for him tell him yourself it is fun
to watch these two squirrels admittedly this is
a short run time so I'm starting to get worried
already got the penultimate episode's only 40
minutes 39 minutes with the official run time
minus credits minus recap all right minus ending
credits wow yeah they've got to do a lot fictional
city of London I wish I could go there good
afternoon Sonia have you heard about this was it
trolls could be amongst us well if you ask
me sir I think they're bloody everywhere
oh politely asking the location of Dr
Rosa Dalton have you lost your mind woman
showing director weatherby's true colors
the last inform you that the sis has
no official policy on killing Scrolls
to enact my personal preference
right now you should stop talking
yeah I'm just happy when she's sunscreen it's on
your mind soldier I was just a little confused
are you confused about can I not
call you g once he's awake I'll send
confirmation of the strike yeah because
you know what happens if you don't run
yeah I was wondering about that new today
grew tan your way through this man
yeah I guess or other abilities that
have yet to be uncovered Frost
giant skills something at least
take his pants off tickle him
oh
cool that was cool that was really cool
wow nice hit this episode got stunts
man you guys suck there's like so many
I'm nothing but a monster
ha all right a mask sure does look funny it's a
big old Noggin that way the ears were bouncing
what the hell you doing
Talos died
he's not dead he died on a
foreign planet on a foreign Road
nothing will come of it Revenge because I knew he
would lose Talos chose the path of struggle he did
not lose you cannot let grief paralyze you Gaia
this is your time now she just started grieving
what DNA did Robert steal only a few
samples collapsody and Flora Colossus
what was he looking for
something he called the Harvest
what's the Harvest it's a big
pumpkin I need to bury my father
take him to Priscilla she'll know
what to do oh [__] it's like the
siren started right outside that window
surprise him he'll never find us here
hello Scrolls
who are you I think a more apt question
would be who would you like me to be I'm
staggeringly versatile I'm very good at
being your bestie I'm also devilishly good
at being not your bestie it's really
just a matter of taste Cake or Death
Nigel and my name's Victor
Nigel's the one with his
silencer pressed against the base of your skull
now start from the very beginning and
don't miss out a damn decimal point really
is a lovely laboratory unfortunately
I'm going to have to torches blow it
well done Nigel which has now been overtaken by
Lucifer as a more popular baby name let us go or
a killer males in my species are very similar
if they're not busy gaslighting you they're
threatening you as murder that's what all the
podcasts are about hey woke whoa she ain't wrong
I liked her until she started shoving agendas down
my throat just talking points of the liberal Elite
she's gonna save Priscilla
so adorable she's such a small person I know I'm
Gaia Theory said you could help me bury my father
Heavenly music that sort of play oh Mr
President what you see on the screen
is the squirrel compound that's Russian
soil we have to neutralize this facility
I would rather us face a war than Extinction
and that's exactly what a scroll Invasion will
mean we have to cut this thing off the head
do you never put on your armor suit Rhody
you're never just like I'll handle it
I can probably do that real quick yeah
but I won't carpet on this one little
location permission I got a deal for you
got anything to do with the Harvest bring it
to me in person I'll call the whole thing off
if I don't get what I want your president's
going to bomb new scrollers bring some
iodide pills the reactor room can be touch
aggressive sure I guess y'all radiated up
I feel a lot better if we were on the helical
yeah that's been mothballed a little bit like
you should be oh voila figured you
might need that on the other side
you're welcome that's a call back try
and get a nap leave my little grumpy
spin-off he deserves a procession of
mourners Dallas wasn't much for a
pageantry do you have the offering
I feel like the first few episodes
are a lot more strikingly shot it's
kind of going back to sort of a
general Blanchard simpler way of
shooting I wonder if it's like they
shoot in chronological order and just
budget or time or they get tired it's hot
sleep no I'll just put the camera anywhere
insubordination I guess and yet you decided
to obey the audio that says you have to wait
around here for your execution the thing is I
love this house it's got a lot of equity in it
I wasn't sure if he'd ever commit to calling
any one place home that need to find a place
that offered the three things he valued most lots
of privacy lots of security and lots of leather
light where's the playroom he'd sit
there by the window reading a book
letting the sun kiss his skin freaking
out how he couldn't see out of one eye
he ever get lost watching you in your
own skin that's none of your business
you don't know what it takes to build
a life with someone else to sustain it
to buy all this green stuff for your house
I did like how that whole dialogue exchange
was in one shot though they just let the actors
act when it comes to facing down my executioners
I'd rather meet the bastard standing right here
than to meet them running down some dark alley
are on some Highway
oh wowie Green Lasers green plants
Gia okay
come on let's Atomic blonde this [__]
oh nice Sarah
before he got through yes
thank you
it's a little leg kick
boom murder them
yeah nice
all right
is he wearing white face
is he white chicksing this
Mission Impossible face pull billion dollars
of research and development and all the Widow's
Veil can cloak as your face what about the
rest of you that's the newer version not
this one we will see it in a different property
this is what we're doing yes this is absolutely
I know exactly how far that is
nearly every avenger spilled blood in the battle
ah woof in the aftermath some were sent in to
collect that DNA some of that blood produces
Iron Man armor yes it definitely does nobody
knew about them but me and the collectors
so you are responsible for all this yeah
how do you think I came back
whatever is in the crown I mean were you
aware that that's what he was trying to do
the Harvest I from that early on
yeah I mean maybe just the blind
threats from Gravity he you know extrapolated out
Scandinavian Cemetery should have brought my
Scythe only dead man keep secrets you taught
me that son dead men tell no Tales oh there it is
Ezekiel Fury why haven't you called any of your
special friends down you can't keep depending on
these superheroes to swoop in and save our asses
it is when we're on the brink of World War III
none of them can defend the world the way I can
that ain't enough yeah I don't know what
hope we have if that ain't enough maybe I am
just dust I get what you're
saying but also you assemble
the Avengers yeah Priscilla in that
honeymoon here Scrolls like the cold
oh she didn't know
you understand uh I hope Olivia
Coleman sticks around yeah
like Fifth Element [__] they do say Darwin never
sleeps let's give our Extinction a nice leg up
why did they give her an actual
sympathetic scene yeah they're
just being cut just joy and
murder yeah three modes now
oh yeah there's the jacket just for
the eye patch I feel like you could
have kept a couple of these
things in the same drawer but
gotta have space yeah he's a
big space guy minimalism the
patch is back he's Fury again let's finish this
Boogie
Kobe smolders oh cause the TV I always
every time I'm I'm struck by that alrighty
all righty well well ladies and gentlemen I I feel
like we should just talk about it right now right
now because so much happened everything there was
just chaos oh my God there's a crazy cacophony of
events it's a display of duplicitousness and an
overwhelming of any show it is a show of Duality
and duplicity to be fair all right dichotomies koi
what is the first topic you think we should talk
about uh I like the leveling up of the Betrayal
of Fury that he had no actual direct cause and
I like that Fury is always like recovering from
his own mistakes I like that we've seen now the
depths of that and that he didn't really learn
from his other lessons like I feel like Nick Fury
is this great uh fallible character so I really
enjoyed him being the one responsible for graphics
uh original idea so harvesting the ruins from the
past yes because Nick Fury in the comics is always
like like oh I did a thing and I've got to really
figure it out and how to recover it and they they
captured that here that is true they did capture
it well John what did you think of his reasoning
not to call in The Avengers I thought it was uh uh
I'm of two minds about it I understand on the one
hand you know the brilliant tactician's mind is
certainly one of the greater assets however given
the physical nature of this conflict I do feel
it's a little maybe short-sighted not to involve
someone who could intervene on a cosmic level
uh so maybe not the best writing decision given
what we know this universe is capable of it seems
like the show being very pressured to be like well
we're doing a ground level show so we have to keep
to that even though we're going up against Scrolls
who now have super powers and who are gonna start
a World War some of our most tense allies I don't
know if you're aware he got his eye patch back
everything yeah come on patch back I'm a pistol he
is fully a superhero again he is Nicholas J Fury
yes uh I mean I enjoyed the action in this episode
um yeah the stunts were solid I enjoyed um
the the leveling up but I definitely worry
that there's one left this episode of Shine
for stunts and foreseen work I think this was
the first episode though that okay yes I'll take
it one subject at a time instead of compounding
these two subjects into one whoa what are
you guys doing we're at a buffet right now
this is a singular plot let's talk about the
action while we're talking about Pros okay
it was it was fine it was good it was good I
like that I liked Priscilla yeah and Emilia
Clark Gaia bang banging it up and uh them
taking on a whole Squad of people they're
just that highly trained and yeah I think in terms
of gun play and some violence even even the Mutiny
moment against graphic was well directed well
well done worked reasonably violent and and
um hit just enough doesn't quite capture
anything I would say is visceral but
it's enjoyable uh and I think that it's inventive
at times like it's still you know very good for a
a TV show like it does at the moments it's got
little pops I would I would say yes to that too
I'm sensing a certain tone here this overall
tone of this review is exactly what you hope
for Creative versus the show started off with
a very different tone in these reviews and it
is it is uh it is taking a certain direction
that we will wait till episode six before we
get so interesting that these shows tend to have
this we are not done with the subjects course
all right this is the most um Emilia
Clarke we have gotten I think is that
correct I'd say this in the first episode
this was very heavily focused on her
she gets to be more of her own character as of
this episode with no one to be part of no one
else's story to be a part of it's more her journey
through this I think the writing and direction is
all uh making it feel flat though with what she's
going through gotta say it I gotta call it out uh
I don't think that this should be like her the
whole thing is like she's grieving and she's
gotta make the she's got I don't know some [__]
about going on a path or something right yeah
yeah and the entire time I was like oh yeah
this has like it seems like it's getting
lost in the void of where emotion should be
it's really interesting because the show uh
is all the same director it's all the same
mapped out budget it knows what it needs to
be and it's it's like clockwork where these
shows have a point where it's like oh what
happened yeah it's beginning to feel a lot like
Christmas I don't want to say yeah definitely
it needs to be more and less at once it's
becoming more by the numbers and less exciting
and less thrilling less everything that was
really great about the first couple episodes
and you started to see a little bit of signs
in the third episode and those signs started
to magnify the fourth and then here I'm like okay
this is the first time I feel like the shadow has
been cast in terms of the problems that have been
just kind of coming through the weeds yeah taking
over that it is a it is a house on the sand that
is so that sand has been going over to the house
is is what I'm feeling because it's by no means
terrible no it is by no means terrible it and
maybe you guys feel different which I'm uh good
for you if you are able to watch this and feel
differently when watching it uh but I think a
lot of the uh striking visual components uh are
are definitely way more absent than ever and and
yeah I'm just talking from a storytelling point I
mean are there some MCU stuff of exciting things
to come maybe uh but at this point I'm like that
doesn't really matter matters is just making a
good show and this one uh we're not done with
Goods let's shift a little bit Olivia Goldman
Lily Coleman always believes absolutely it's
pure joy incarnate every dialogue Choice like
I like that you could read the sentences from
a lesser actor and it'd be like well that's just
dialogue but she makes it Punchy like she's really
good at making dialogue that shouldn't work
sing and has great chemistry with Sam Jackson
everybody's going yeah yeah but it's impressive
yeah and I like the way she is very free to do
a character and I feel like Sam Jackson has been
very free to like put a lot of his own soul into
this I feel like he feels more not just like
Sam Jackson but someone who's bringing you know
the struggles of their own life to a story that
at least wants to be big and impactful and also
he's got some of his flavor and Rhythm and it's
fun to see him in a Marvel situation where he
is allowed to really kind of spread his wings
a little bit in the limited scenes that allow
for that uh I think my favorite character is
Priscilla she is the best character she's the
most interesting character or the actress
what is her name uh Charlene Woodard she's
she's just so natural and and like I just love
watching her she draws me in she's just got so
much life every turn she takes I really enjoyed
the and I like that he pointed out the dialogue
it was like a lock-off shot we just like lived
in but that turn felt so earned but also like
her recovering from the emotion also felt so
worm like not only does she have a moment of
like raw emotion because of something she said but
also like her and this is you being this and like
I was just really impressed she seems to be one
of the few characters who convincingly at least
who like emotionally exists at that fulcrum
of like being in the heart of a really tough
you know political like geo-astropolitical
situation but also someone who was having like
this personal struggle and who has just a really
interesting I don't know this is the life they've
given her as a character is easily the most
interesting yeah she doesn't try to play it like
overly dramatic she just feels like a real human
being and I love that the history of her actually
seems like she has been here the whole time you
know and not just because this is a character
who you're implying has been part of Nick Fury's
life the past few decades right and that he's had
a secret wife this whole time and Secret Lives
Secret Life Secret Life Invasion uh is that you
feel it it see it's like oh yeah I can I actually
got the sense that she really not only understands
her character but the Marvel world and everything
like that I think she does it I think she does
a phenomenal job and anytime she's been here I'm
like you have been a an absolute welcome addition
graphic um is uh he's going down a path that I saw
a comments on one on our last video it was like
how did graphic end up a better villain than Gore
and you know then it turned into a whole other
conversation about tiger watiti of course but the
uh but Graphics great I think graphic is great
again it to me everything just felt like it
was sort of getting undercut by trimming uh
things being too short and the just the overall
like because before it was like all right maybe
this is a little short but I'm at least liking the
way this is being directed yeah and now I really
like the writing I like this scene yeah now I'm
like no a lot of this is not really singing that
loud anymore and so and even the teamwork feels
sacrificed for it that's my point is like the
things that the actors are still showing up and
doing a great job but all the scene work stuff
that was once like well this makes up for it is
now not feeling like it's making up for it now
because it's it it's it's like wow this is going
quicker and quicker when it when it doesn't feel
like the It doesn't feel like intensity is ramping
up it doesn't feel like uh Stakes are ramping
up even if you have Graphics saying I'm raising
the state it does not feel like things are truly
ramping up it it just seems like they're now just
trying to get it over with it yeah a little bit
and to me it feels like like a missed opportunity
in this sense and we'll see how it ends you know
it could there could be a tremendous finale coming
our way but I feel like this is highlighting
something that has been a curiosity to me since
this show started which was okay I know Falcon and
the Winter Soldier was an attempt to do something
kind of in this vein but that was hampered by a
lot of outside real world circumstances this
doesn't have that so now we're moving into a
piece of the story where I'm like okay this
is all very familiar the bad guy for whatever
his political aspirations are and his you know
his Uprising you know whole philosophy is he's
basically just trying to get a magic McGuffin so
he can get really powerful and then cause a lot of
Destruction and then we gotta stop it and that's
pretty familiar and it doesn't really take this
whole world war three and like ooh we're gonna
create like a false flag situation or something
where you know we have them bomb us to create this
spark of oh our people are gonna think we're being
attacked and all the Russians are gonna think
they're being attacked like it it pays face
value to that stuffer or lip service to that stuff
but I don't really think that they've committed to
like having a political thriller that's really
a political thriller yeah um yeah what are you
gonna do you know it's not like you can make this
stuff better it's just it's really interesting
part it just started so strong for me and it is
an odd tradition of of Disney plus yeah like Loki
got better um and and like Wanda Vision was like
five out of six for me but like the the rest of
all felt like diminishing returns like in one way
or another whether it's Hawkeye being something
that's really fun and novel and Buddy copy but
then like as soon as they introduce a character
we want to be you know more like something we know
it's just like oh and then it's just the last the
last little bit of that show felt left like it
Falcon the Winter Soldier it felt like it had
to take a left turn in order to recover I don't
know it's just it's really interesting because
you know the show is gonna end away when you start
making it yeah it's just really odd to like let
that happen again yeah proportions do seem very
strange for the way they've done a lot of these
show and yeah it's like one Division and Loki
set this tone where you're like yeah cool like
you could have maybe gone one or one more but
like mostly everything's there and now lately
it's either been like too long or Too Short
like and yeah there's like a sweet spot that
I don't know if they have found more werewolf by
night yeah or one-offs yeah all righty well guys
ah this is my least favorite episode of the season
so far I'm gonna leave it at that we'll see how
the entire package ends up being delivered
by the end here is your least favorite yeah
probably it's got the least cohesive amalgamation
of everything there are still good moments but
yeah this is not the most cohesive it's goddess
moments but everything constantly just kept
feeling like being cut too short and so you kept
feeling like they were like onto the next thing
onto the next thing wait there was a lot of like
Martini shot Martini you would think that there
would be a button or some kind of Coda to a
lot of things or or things would constantly
feel like okay now we're starting to cook oh wait
we're cutting away again and we're resetting the
build of momentum yeah odd very odd penultimate
alrighty well you're looking at a three satisfied
fans man oh man do we feel complete um what do
you guys think let us know down below but we'll
of course come back for the finale hopeful hopeful
it's gonna be good that they that they go you know
what let's make this great um gray tick subscribe
this is like okay thoughts down below we will be
a coffee coach come visit us thank you thank you
guys for um for being here yep yep um hey I think
let's shout out a patron why don't why don't we do
that after that exit they're gonna love it whoever
I want to be on this episode I am this is the
one this is what I want please please shout me
out flev Doran flavor are you liking it are you
liking this flavor you're uh you're a big fan of
all these properties you you you're like yeah this
is my jam right here this is what I want flip door
is a good scroll name yeah pretty sure he made
this exact same thing to dig back in the archives
did we do Flav in another I remember every single
time someone repeats a joke I like that you don't
remember other stuff you've got this weird bag
of like I've been remembered Joker that's gonna
be my thing because it's not funny now and now I'm
upset 100 original joke well that's how much it's
a scroll name yeah it's level we'll correct this
but it's like I'm in my patreon either way while
this episode did not fill us with life you fill us
with life constantly so because your energy is is
like when do you remember at the end of Pokemon
uh the movie no he actually didn't do that in
the movie uh in the movie when we thought Ash was
dead yeah and then all the Pokemon cried and their
tears welcome back on love yeah they resurrected
him yeah from the dead that's where you are like
for us you are the Pokemon's tears you're the very
best that no one was before humanoids for life so
thank you fled for being you and for always being
here and I hope you have a great week samsies